стенди і з позовом про скупа на галині майже
на шкіряному вкоротимо для такого бізнесу
потрібно зовсім мало
крил сосиски щось пристрели для чоловіка
вести оплати кредитну картку та випивку та
розплачується по суті лиж та туристи
in vertical перетворишся наприкінці
робочого дня колими педро прячем овочі в
касі купюр там стало значно менше
витрат я отримала роботу менше може
або країни правильно дата здачу ми не
то моїм колегам непотрібно томати
половиною тата слідів його робочого дня
20 уроки в the movie 70 років на добу
своїх покупок данте сплачував агуті фку
їм сьогодні таких менш нижче 25 сотки
плитку на стелю шоу плач у цю карту -
собою унікальний і мого тіла проблема
cool обирають простіше над заручини з розуму
на нікола німає щоб у класу dusk
ринку а джея вершину карстовий бутил
задаємо ім'я на сольналь the people
перебуваєш плями поглядом люди їх не
жити залишити абсолютно прозрачна meal
імені з одна ранка
малюка пробач данте дають право
викликати у кого муразор хунг у вікторії
розривний турнір чи всерйоз думаєте
провітамін сплати товарі в пляшку та в
донські марія аптек матос покупки вже
кількома міситами може оплачувати товари
через мобільні телефони
але висновків не засовуєте у всіх
магазинах зажадав і шведського вати
штрих-код хто підтвердить та купівлю
що зійшов не стоять черги на касу в я
вінчестер ми за ті кого не в тому ще
подбайте про черевик
обидві гарні турбуєшся до вбив
стала дуже дорогим йому б смішно ми
хочемо досвід щоб ну ти процес переходи
на мобілі не платить аліменти
весь процес донські піт наступництво та
кіно продають продукти харчування скоро
може театр мод і чоловіки повністю
видно ось ці види плат цього рейтингу
їм алла політики це управління
центральному банку по канаві значилося з
дату та курки вигляд будете ви і звернутися
проблема зубів я за не треба ти нлп
але суму телиця для населення та компанії
наша робота in java боці ми обожнюємо а
що увійшли вам від і ефективну то б
смішно платіжну інфраструктуру процес
Незабаром дуже його витрат на платежі та пари
хіт на цифру вигляд вони навіть важливі
такі на великі краї не ягода не
контролю кальмар стенди з хот-догом і в
дружини паркану може друкувати примати
мобільні платежі
витрати на даті ви хрестові мобільні до
дати які у чоловіка чи я так оплату
товарів продавати до ви доручивши ж прямо
та оплата через мобільний телефон для
випивки в його маленькому вагончику
умістивши ж майдану і втратила а